we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P here's a caller who's
calling in about my Tesla lease I'm not
exactly sure what point they want to
make
hey David so I'm in the market for a
Tesla I know you're releasing soon
I'll give you 40 grand for it let me
know bye okay so I don't know what point
they're trying to make listen one of the
things I said uh a while ago when I
decided to lease a Tesla I generally
lease anyway because it provides
um uh tax advantages if you have a an S
corporation and uh I've explained I just
maintenance all the I explained all my
my financial reasons for going with
Elise
um in in particular with Tesla one of
the reasons I wanted to Lisa not buy was
number one a lot of the reliability data
particularly after three years is pretty
damn shaky and I want the maintenance on
a four-year-old Tesla to be someone
else's problem and not mine and I've
I've said before the range unbelievable
the charging Network fantastic better
than any other brand but
build quality very shaky the car's been
in the shop multiple times for the same
thing they have it seven to ten days
they don't fix it they give me a loaner
that's been beaten to hell
um all this stuff long story short I
don't want to own a Tesla and so that's
the deal with the lease it is true that
because Tesla cut prices on these cars
multiple times
if I owned the car now it would have
lost dramatically probably I mean more
than ten thousand dollars in value maybe
even closer to 20. so that's another
reason I'm really glad that I don't own
this thing and I can just walk away from
the dramatically depreciated vehicle now
this guy wants to buy me out of my lease
for 40 Grand I don't know what the lease
buyout is at this point I haven't looked
at it but uh email me and we can talk
about it maybe I'll maybe I'll send you
my car all right a bonus show today
Bernie Sanders has endorsed Joe Biden
and is ruling out running in 2024. there
are people who wrote to me saying Bernie
had to do it why that doesn't make any
sense we'll talk about it number two
Missouri is about to force trans adults
and teens to de-transition the ACLU is
suing what on Earth is happening in
Missouri and lastly Justice John Roberts
Chief Justice of the Supreme Court is
declining an invitation from the Senate
to testify on the ethics of the Supreme
Court I am sure that Clarence Thomas's
name would come up at such a hearing
we'll talk about all of it on today's
bonus oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad David
Pacman does not have a soul he doesn't
have a soul you can make heads or tails
out of those comments if you want but I
tell you the bonus show is a good time
sign up at joinpakman.com we will see
you on the bonus show